called Hungry often injured conditions
have worsened for refugees on the Poland
Belarus border Aid workers and activists
call this fence Poland's first line of
torture we've seen a huge increase in
people with serious medical conditions
since the world's been built we knew it
from the beginning that this war will
not stop a migration and it doesn't stop
anyone from from crossing the border and
there are many people who lost their
lives in this forest and people who are
lost but compared to for example
Mediterranean Sea it's still relatively
safe the Polish government says defense
is important to stop what it considers
illegal migration it's deploying
thousands of additional troops on the
border but so far this year 19 000
people have attempted to cross that's
higher than the total number last year
it was only activists who started
bringing help to people in need and we
meet many people from many many places
people who
flee countries with a difficult
difficult economic situation or
countries at War it's very much related
to a difficult situation in the country
of origin of people on the move for
example as you said last two months we
see many people from Sudan it's not
illegal to help people but activists
have faced charges such as helping
Smugglers when they try to provide Aid
to refugees one time when border guards
found me and my friend in the forest
they kicked her really hard and you meet
people in the forest who are extremely
terrified exhausted
uh quite often sick who need
uh who didn't eat or or drunk water for
many many days
you give them these very basic stuff and
then you have to leave them in the
forest quite often at night when we got
to the place
yeah turns out that nothing we had to
would have been enough because the
person
has been dead already
um he's been dead for
at least several hours in water in the
swamp
that was the worst experience that I've
had
what should governments do what is a
perfect solution
I don't think the answer is to decrease
migration I think we have to stop
thinking of of this world is you know
some
part that certain people have the right
to and other people don't why do Polish
people migrate to UK or United States
everyone deserves living in a safe place
everyone deserves opportunities for
Education everyone deserves to to have a
home and to have their human rights
respected and until that happens people
will likely continue to risk lives to
find safety and a better future
Poland